[Music]
good morning John it's Wednesday March
28th today is not really good day
because today is tax day for me anyways
I've gotten two different kinds of forms
there's a w-2 and that's kind of a good
one because all the Texas already been
taken out and so you just have to send
it in and then they give you money back
and the 1099 is for stuff that you
haven't paid taxes on yet so up until
now I've usually had a w-2 and maybe a
couple 299 things have changed these are
my 1099 s there's like twelve of them of
course when you look at them they're
actually kind of funny you got your
rents your royalties your other you know
everything else goes into other except
fishing boat proceeds I don't even know
what a fishing boat pro Cee'd is but
apparently it's not other it's its own
category also a big fan of this one
excess golden parachute payments this
year I didn't have any excess golden
parachute payments so that's what I'm
doing today
taxes not fun definitely my last video
was more awesome but with all the people
putting stuff on their heads this is a
pretty snug fit I like I like a pony
tail it's very exciting to hear that
you're feeling better I admit there were
some times after looking up your disease
on the internet that I was kind of
really worried but it seems like you're
doing a lot better people don't
generally die from orbital cellulitis I
mean they used to but now we have
penicillin and so things are better some
people have been calling attention to
the fact that I have good posters and I
tend to agree made a decision when I was
in college that I would always have one
room in my house that was decorated like
a college dorm room right now that room
is the office where I make these videos
and also the office where I work and am
most of every day cowboy bebop poster
number one stuff on my cat poster you
can spend a lot of time looking at this
poster Hey look hi
Here I am cat with little
dougies go to stuff on my cat calm form
or speaking of stuff on cats this is the
pirate Kitty Catherine and I have had
the pirate Kitty for an awful long time
map of the world map of the realm of
Narnia pretty pictures from a calendar
that I cut out and put in a big frame
might be giant slug poster inuyasha
poster cowboy bebop poster number doop
yes they are giant pictures of Katherine
and I as babies some other things not
currently on my wall but I kind of wish
they were include this Ranson poster
this amazing thing that my friend would
you made for me this my placemat from
the first restaurant where I eat with
Katherine's family this amazing
Valentine's Day card it's got a big
carrot another collage thing from my
past Spice Girls stubble on five even
better this adorable wrapping paper from
a Valentine's Day present Katherine gave
me it's a heart and then the heart
opened and becomes an apple and in the
app opens it becomes a penguin oh my god
that's cute and that's all I have for
you today commenter chuck noted that
this has kind of become a girly place
and I just showed you some baby pictures
and also a Valentine's Day card from
Katherine that was pretty adorable and I
just want to say that we're not
marketing specifically towards women
we're guys and we'd like guys to watch
Brotherhood 2.0 and pizza and beer
sounds great me John can help you out
with that
next show if not I'll see what I can do
so hopefully you'll be eating pizza and
beer in home tomorrow which is what I'll
see you tomorrow
I'll see you tomorrow